el número 50 es cinco veces más grande
que 10 escribe esta comparación como una
ecuación multiplicativo y lo que
queremos va a ser en la respuesta
colocar esta ecuación tenemos entonces
que 50
es igual a 5 veces el número 10
y porque lo sabemos porque esta estrella
nos representa el símbolo de
multiplicación si nosotros colocamos una
equis no lo entendería lo tomaría como
5x como una variable sin embargo tenemos
5 x y eso lo coloco con shift y el
símbolo de más y lo multiplicó por 10
entonces 50 es igual a 5 veces 10 si yo
tomo 5 veces 10 unidades tendré 50 vamos
a checar la respuesta
es correcto hagamos un par más de estos
que son son divertidos para ver qué
tanto hemos entendido el número seis es
tres veces más grande que tres esta
comparación utiliza la adición también
podemos hacer esta comparación
utilizando la multiplicación y en el
espacio para completar la comparación si
yo tuviera tres veces tres qué número es
el que sería mi origen 99 es tres veces
más grande que tres es decir tenemos
tres bloques de tres sumaremos nueve
obtendremos la multiplicación de tres
por tres comprobemos la respuesta
y es correcto vamos a hacer una última
el número 24 es cuatro veces más grande
que 6 vamos a escribir esta comparación
como una ecuación multiplicativo tenemos
que el 24
es igual a 4 veces
el número 6 si yo tengo cuatro bloques
de seis unidades tendré 24 o de igual
manera si tuviera seis bloques de cuatro
unidades tendré en total 24
vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta
y es correcta